let's now dig
let's now dig a little bit deep deeper
into the lawrence transformation in
particular let's put some numbers here
so that where we get a little bit more
familiar manipulating it and then we'll
start to get a little bit more intuition
on how this transformation or sometimes
it's talked as spoken of in the plural
the transformations behave so let's pick
the scenario in which our friend passes
us by and this is the same scenario
we've been doing in previous videos with
a relative velocity from my frame of
reference at half the speed of light so
the magnitude of her velocity is half
the speed of light she is moving in the
positive x direction and our space-time
diagrams they coincide at the origin and
so let's pick an event in space time and
so let's say from in my coordinate
system in my frame of reference this
event that we focused on in the last
video let's say that is that x is equal
to
one meter
x is in that same color x is equal to
one meter and let's say that time or ct
is also equal to one meter and like we
said in i think several videos ago we
could view this as a light meter the
time it takes for light to go one meter
so we will also say this is one meter so
in my coordinate system in my frame of
reference this would be the point one
comma one one meter in the x direction
one meter in the ct direction now based
on that think about what what would be
the prime coordinates what would be the
coordinates in her frame of reference
and i encourage you to pause the video
evaluate the lawrence factor using v and
c
and then and then evaluate what x prime
and c t prime would be
all right i'm assuming you've had a go
at it now let's work through this
together so first let's figure out what
the lorentz factor actually let's first
figure out what beta would be that'll
simplify everything so a beta let me do
that blue color
beta
in this
case is going to be equal to
0.5 c that's her relative velocity in my
frame of reference the ratio between
that and the speed of light so that's
just going to be equal to
0.5 you could just view beta as what
fraction of the speed of light is that
is that person traveling in in the in
the reference or in in my frame of
reference since we're using that as kind
of the non-primed frame of reference and
so let's now think about what gamma is
going to be the lorentz factor the
lorentz factor is going to be i'm doing
that reddish color not the magenta it is
going to be
so gamma is going to be 1 over
the square root of 1
minus beta squared beta squared is
well 0.5 squared is going to be
0.25 actually let me just write 0.5
squared just so that you see what i'm
doing so this is
0.5 squared and if we were to evaluate
that let's see this is going to be 1
minus
0.25 so it's going to be 0.75 so this is
going to be equal to
this is going to be equal to 1 over the
square root of 0.75 1 over the square
root of 0.75
let me get my calculator out we can at
least approximate it so
0.75 let's take the square root and now
let's take the reciprocal of that so
approximately
1.15
so
our lawrence factor is approximately
is approximately 1.15
and now using that we can figure out
what x prime and ct prime are going to
be
x prime
x prime is going to be equal to my
lawrence factor which is approximately
1.15
so maybe i'll write it as approximately
going to be equal to
one do that same color
is going to be
one point i'm having trouble switching
colors today
1.15
times
now we're saying x is 1 meter
so
x is 1 meter
minus beta beta is 0.5
so
0.5
and ct we're also saying is one meter
so times
times one
and then t prime or i should say ct
prime
c t prime is going to be approximately
the lorentz factor
1.1
i always have trouble switching colors
for the lawrence factor it's going to be
approximately equal to 1.15
times
well ct is 1. i think you see a little
bit of symmetry here and this one in
particular because it had the same
same x and ct coordinates so 1
minus
beta
1 minus beta so 0.5
times x which is once again 1.
so times 1. and so in this particular
case it simplifies to half of the
lorentz factor because
this 1 minus 0.5 times 1 that's just
going to be 0.5
and same thing over here 0.5 so these
things are going to be approximately
equal to
0.5 times the lorentz factor we already
had the lawrence factor in my calculator
so let me just
multiply by 0.5 and i get it's
approximately
0.5 i'll just say 0.58
so
0.58
0.58 and once again the the units are in
meters so even though this is one meter
and one meter this over here x prime is
0.58
0.58 meters and ct prime is also
0.58 meters
so this is also equal to 0.58
meters so one way to think about it if
right when r2 when right as she was
passing me at x equals zero time equals
zero in my frame of reference i were to
i were to shoot my laser gun or i would
turn my flashlight on and that very
first photon
starts traveling and so i could think
about its path through space-time it
would look that very first photon
would look something like
would look something like that
when i think that a when i think that
that photon has traveled
one meter in the positive x direction
and one light meter of time has passed
from my frames for my friend's frame of
reference she would say no no no i
exactly that moment let's say it hits an
asteroid at that moment it lights up an
asteroid she would say no no that that
happened 0.58
light meters after she passed me up and
it happened
0.58 meters in the positive x direction
so something very very very interesting
is going on and i encourage you to think
about what's actually going on with
these different parts of the lorentz
transformations the most interesting is
what's going on well actually it's all
interesting in fact the symmetry is
interesting but the lorentz factor think
about what's happening here think about
what's happening here for low velocities
when v is a very very very small
fraction of the speed of light well then
beta is going to be pretty close to zero
and then the lorentz factor is going to
be pretty close to one and think about
what happens when v approaches the speed
of light well then this thing just booms
this thing gets larger and larger and
larger as because we as we see this
denominator getting smaller and smaller
and smaller and if v were actually equal
to the speed of light well then you're
going to be you're going to be dividing
by zero so you know that that also all
sorts of silliness starts to happen so
really encourage you to to try out
different numbers we tried very high
relative velocity half the speed of
light incredibly incredibly high
velocity try it out for something more
mundane like like the speed of a bullet
or or something like that but definitely
get very familiar with this and also
manipulated algebraic in fact maybe in
the next video i'll manipulate this a
little bit algebraically so that you can
reconcile the way i've written the
lawrence transformation or the lawrence
transformations with the way that you
might see it in your textbook or other
resources